think about driving mountain roads
there'll be a little pullover and a
vista stop and you look at this little
perspective
while that's beautiful now imagine doing
that every second there's a new Vista
and it's just one amazing scene after
another and a perspective that you only
get from fly
this airplane is designed to allow you
to explore your planet a very
interactive way like no other airplane
can change the way you see the world it
really does
the kind of fun that we're talking about
is not where you're sitting in aluminum
tube crammed with tiny seat a little
window fine we're talking about is low
altitude looking out the front window
open windows in fact the windows decide
winners and these open up the impetus
for icon really is about regulations
change and the FAA proposed two things a
new category of aircraft called the
light sport aircraft and a new license
called the sport pilot together with
those with those two major changes do
they really open up flying think about
sports cars boats motorcycles jet skis
ATVs it's like that kind of the world
there's two things this airplane is
designed to do and that is to resonate
both of the most elite pilots I mean I
was a fighter pilot where we have guys
who get in or airline pilots and look at
the cockpit and they go look if I want
to go and have fun and I want to fly in
daytime good weather and go out with my
friends and just enjoy recreational
flying they get in the cockpit and go
perfect that's all I need
alright that's it and then we have the
new pilots who would look at the cockpit
and go that's it that's all I need
we take a very design centric approach
focused on the total human experience
from the time you touch the vehicle from
them you open the canopy or get in or
move a knob or something all these
details are thought through very very
carefully by very smart people
it's built out of carbon fiber it's a
high-strength lightweight material that
you'll see and falafels instead GPS
moving map in it so your awareness is
very high we have an optional built in
parachute you don't intend to use it but
if you end up with it deployed you're
kind of glad you had it the most unique
thing about this airplane this
particular model is amphibious fibbies
means it can take off and land just as
easily on the water as it can on the
land you can take off at the airport fly
the local Lake Caribbean back mountains
there's an automatic wing fold version
and that allows you a couple things when
you can store it a small space you can
store it at your house you can trailer
it it's designed to be easily
transportable it's it's very easy to fly
for one it's very safe and docile and
easy to fly it lands at 45 miles an hour
it takes about 45 miles an hour if you
buy a nikon aircraft and you don't have
a sport license then don't worry about
it we will actually provide that
training you can come to the plant pick
your airplane up learn to fly you can
get your license to be a sport pilot in
about two weeks and about three to four
thousand dollars
we flew the flying prototype about a
month ago now which flew extremely well
it's a lot more flight testing yet to be
done
we were scheduled for the first
production deliveries in late 2010 what
we're doing is it takes something that's
historically been extremely technical
and move it into consumer market and do
so with great understanding of human
beings human interface great designs
great engineering
when you first learn to fly in this
you're going to be surprised at how easy
flying actually can be
you